winter is coming and the dragon and the
wolf season finale for season seven of
Game of Thrones and yeah that is a heck
of a way to close out the season there
was a lot that went out on in this thing
and frankly I am NOT gonna remember to
talk about everything that I want to
because there were obviously a ton of
big moments I'll get to those but there
were a lot of small moments that I loved
and I treasured it I would love to name
all them and I'm gonna forget some let's
get ramblin this is not gonna be spoiler
free I mean it's the season finale of
course I'm gonna talk spoilers but
there's so many great little moments and
reunions between characters that I
really loved I really loved Brienne and
the house first of all she's only like
an inch shorter than him I knew she was
tall but waah
and then just this sort of them talking
about Aria there was this air of you
know what it was like it was like
divorced parents who don't get along but
like are still proud of the kid they
raised that like felt that was the
feeling out of them talking about Aria
and I love that it was like this little
bonding moment between them and it was
really awesome and you know projects
back in he gets his moment with Tyrion
which is immediately undercut by bran I
love bran so much and men that that
meeting in that that pit the dragon pit
that all the tension in that room holy
crap
again nicely cut by your on trying to
make it about him and nobody's standing
for it not even serious this is I I
would rather hear from the brother who I
hate possibly more than anyone else on
the planet than from you but that was
they really had me wondering how is this
gonna go out because you know there's
Searcy holding around like I'm not
dealing with you people and then they
there's a dead man lunging at her how
cool would have been if the Hound just
hadn't quite pulled back on the chain
early enough and it just got into her
just saying
but you know that whole thing and I know
reaction very genuine to that and I met
that was the thing with Searcy is that
she really sold every step of this thing
she sold the know I'm putting my foot
down she sold the shock of it then she
sold the you know the whole you know I'm
I am bitter and spiteful enough that if
you're not gonna do this the way I say
we should do it that I'm not gonna help
you
and then her scene with Tyrion which was
a grazing and both of them just back and
forth and each other you could feel just
the visceral hatred between the two of
them and then she actually sold the idea
that she was going to actively help to
the point that Jaime even believed and I
bought into it I really did think that
look until the army but that is dealt
with as soon as that's dealt with she's
gonna be a massive problem but she's
gonna help here and then you never
disappoint Searcy I actually I take that
back you disappoint me every time but in
the best kind of way like I think maybe
there's a better nature to this
character new fool what a fool I was for
even entertaining that notion for a hot
minute and I props to Jamie calling her
Bluff cuz I I really did think that she
was gonna have the mountain kill him and
man the guts for him to call that Bluff
and walk away
wow I don't know where he goes from here
but Wow
you know there were a number of
characters who I've been iffy on on
their journey but who had wonderful
payoffs here
one of them Theon I've spoken before
about how gratuitous I thought some of
the abuse towards the honest and I think
it may still have been slightly overdone
but I gotta tell you he has become so
compelling as a character because
because we've seen him go through so
much we absolutely understand when he
makes a decision that we don't want him
to make you can't fault him you
absolutely get why he abandoned yara why
he's so cowardly but then for him to
stand up to that guy and he's just
taking these punches and these beatings
and just being told to stay out and he
like for finally he's not I'm not
staying down I'm gonna get up and this
has gotta hurt but I've I've suffered
before and I'll keep suffering and the
guy tries to knee him in the balls
that's gotta be I wasn't gonna be the
first time he was happy to Eddie he gets
this grin it's like I got nothing there
that's your best move and it doesn't
work on me
ah so I'm I'm just
I've really enjoyed where Theon's
journey has led to him as a character I
find him insanely compelling at this
point but you want to talk about a
character I used to not stand like you
back three years ago maybe a little more
she was all my worst characters list she
wouldn't come near it now Sansa that
seen her Arya all those people and the
only one who doesn't know how screwed he
is his little finger he's the only one
in that room who doesn't get it and I've
never seen little finger on the back
foot before I mean there were some times
where I thought maybe he hasn't
orchestrated this maybe he's working on
the fly so I don't think he always had
everything planned to you know to a
meticulous level but he always seemed
prepared to roll with whatever happened
but then this happened and he had not
counted on it he really overestimated
his ability to manipulate Sansa and I
think she had his number
the instant he abandoned her - Ramsay
once that happened but she sold the
vulnerability still so that he thought
he could control her again and I was
afraid he'd be able to but Oh would you
just when she's reading out the charges
and looking at Aria then just turns Lord
Baelish Oh like I know where this is
going and I love it let this moment drag
out and let it last and they let it last
they let them all and play let him
flounder and let her spit his own words
his own advice back at him and then are
you did the thing that I said I wanted
to happen and I didn't think was gonna
happen she killed him with that blade
yeah
oh so good and brand finally proved
useful and that's the Ashley brand
proved useful a little bit he proved
useful and that's seen I'd like to see
with Sam where it gets laid out
explicitly for anyone who hadn't gotten
in and also just to get the details out
of the way exactly what John's
connection to the Targaryen zé's and
Sam's face the oh my god face and also
hit the understanding that he was able
to bring to that so it wasn't just a
case of oh my god how did I not find
this out before but he actually brought
his own information
you know imparting the fact that he's
not a bastard he's legitimate heir and
so all of that and then of course you
know we've got we've got the the wall
not anymore
it's gone now I mean I thank you for you
know after teasing us zombie driving
giving us zombie dragon not maybe making
us wait a year cuz I mean the boy like
wall came down that's a good that's a
good sort of place to stop and cuz that
that is the moment that changes
everything the wall is gone and I have
been afraid that they had teased us with
the zombie dragon we weren't gonna get
the zombie dragon until next season so
thank you for not doing that to us I
have to ask did the tour one guy when
the wall came down I mean we it wasn't
they didn't do a very good job of
establishing where he was on the wall
when it came down and I want to say he
lived cuz we've gotten to the point
where the show kind of is being more
explicit about when characters die and
how but that was that that was a huge
chunk of the wallet I don't know if he
was headed in the right direction to be
in the part that's still standing if he
is alive I wish they had had just one
shot of him looking down at the army as
it moved through the gap or something
because otherwise I'm just I'm gonna be
left wondering until we pick up again or
until you know news of him being on set
when the next season starts shooting
whatever happens first so there's all
that and just there's so much intensity
in this episode there's emotional
intensity there's visceral intensity
there's just all over the place it is
terrific and all again just talking a
little moments how interested
looked when he saw that undead pop out
of that box I'm like that's not good
there anything that interests that man
that much that is not good or just the
moment the Hound had and you're facing
up against the mountain just all these
tiny little things these great little
moments these little interactions these
little reunions between characters
there's almost nothing I don't like
about this episode except one thing and
I remember thinking as the moment was
coming just no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no when they did it in that
is look this is a show where we have
actual on purpose incest do we need to
have accidental incest really I mean I I
know I was one of the few people who
wasn't like oh look at the vibe between
John and Danny and it's not that I
didn't see it it's just that I'd hoped
it was gonna just be a vibe that never
played out but there's something not
only just skeevy but cheaply
manipulative about the fact that we as
an audience find out that they are blood
related at the same time as that as them
you know getting busy and I just I
didn't care for it
I mean well we'll see how the
consequences play out I'm given some of
the stuff that has happened with say
Sansa and Theon and things that I did
not like before ultimately paying off in
good ways I'm not gonna I'm reserving a
certain level of judgment on this
because I want to see how it plays out
because the show has shown me that
sometimes it does something that maybe
isn't great but it's paying off later
now it doesn't always because we had the
weird was it consensual was it not
seeing that I don't think they meant to
- but it came off as rape at Joffrey's
tomb that happened between Searcy and
Jamie and that never led to anything so
we've seen them do things before that
feel like they shouldn't mean anything
and then don't so I I don't have
holy faith unwavering in the show but
certainly in this episode and this
season in general they have done a very
good job of paying off
you know either dangling plot threads or
things that happened a long time ago
that maybe I didn't even care about at
the time or didn't like at the time but
ultimately led to something interesting
so while this is the thing I don't like
about this episode because I think it's
cheap and a little skeevy and kind of
manipulative manipulative of the
audience I am reserving some level of
judgment cuz maybe it'll lead to
something interesting I don't know but
for right now that's my one reservation
and ultimately while while I I do
legitimately not like that moment it's
pretty much the only moment like
everything else about this man that was
great that was such a great way to close
out this season and just leave me just
going why do we have to wait so long for
the last chunk of these episodes man so
season finale of season seven of Game of
Thrones what did you think about this
sucker whatever it was drop something
down in the comments let's talk about it
don't forget to like subscribe check me
out on Twitter right council of geeks
give a listen to the council of geeks
podcast available on iTunes and stitcher
and until next time this council is
adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]